[Music]
so more than 50 years Iggy Pop has
cemented his status as the Godfather of
punk the iconic rocker is best known for
his wild and often unpredictable onstage
antics when we last spoke nearly three
years ago Iggy said he might be done
making music but the rock legend is back
with his 18th solo album free Iggy Pop
has always been a primal performer an
artist who literally bled for his
audience
it was Iggy who invented the stage dive
at 72 he has finally stopped
I haven't stage dived all year you
haven't staged that whole yard I did 12
gigs i I worked the front I'll get in
their faces but I can't I can't do that
anymore I did it I did it up through
last year yeah and if I do it now just
some things liable to detach itself his
last album post pop depression released
in 2016 was his first to crack the top
20 on the pop charts how did that feel
well it sort of felt like okay yeah
exactly it was okay for those of you who
didn't think yeah took care of that but
yeah you don't have to do that every
time this time for his 18th solo album
free iggy is crooning over a jazzier
groove my skills are better than they
were 20 years ago I can I can handle the
tune no and I wanted to do that
Iggy made his name in the late 60s as
the howling frontman for Detroit punk
pioneers the Stooges he remembers trying
to explain his singing to a girlfriend's
father she had told him I was a vocalist
he said well you must saw like Neil
Diamond 1916 I did I did what a big deal
diamond although I recognized his
quality
Iggy is the alter ego of James Osterberg
jr. who's been married since 2008 to
Nina
Alou but she said I couldn't live with
Iggy Pop but I can live with Jim yeah
sure yeah
well that's true
are they two very different people they
should be Jimmy Osterberg grew up in a
trailer park in Ypsilanti Michigan these
are your folks
my father James Auster Byrd senior my
namesake and this is my mother
Jimmy was voted most likely to succeed
in high school but when music became his
passion his father an English teacher
did not approve it seemed like I had in
the clouds a dream to him but at the end
of his life he took my hand and told me
that I'd made my dream come true he did
yeah yeah he's great yeah what did it
mean to you to hear your dad say that at
the end I was shocked at his generosity
he was trying to square things with me a
little bit you know he also told me you
were right about Vietnam this summer
marked the 50th anniversary of the
Stooges debut album but Iggy the last
surviving member saw no reason to
celebrate you turned down a chance to do
a tribute at Madison Square Garden yeah
that would have turned into such a hype
fest I'm not a Madison Square Garden guy
you're not but he did accept a Lifetime
Achievement Award from British GQ there
was no speech thanks thanks you know I
like it like that yeah yeah in a new
book of his lyrics till wrong feels
right it looks back on his career it was
really fun to do the sixties or
seventies by the 80s I'm getting grumpy
and by the 90s he writes he'd become an
endangered species when it turns to the
20th century you say I crawled out of my
dark cave and into the limelight of love
and acceptance
yeah and it's that's tongue-in-cheek
but there's some truth there's a lot of
truth to that he remembers a moment
driving in Miami where he moved in the
90s I pulled into a gas station in my
old Cadillac convertible and I was gonna
open the door to go pump gas and all of
a sudden from two opposite directions
two cop cars come screeching up and
flank me and I thought oh this is cool
feels good yeah not everybody you know
he's an incredibly eloquent and sweet
guy yeah very thoughtful it's so
interesting to me that even at 71 72
yeah you can still get so emotional
about your dad that father said is so
power very very very strong he and he
has enormous respect for his parents
yeah you can say that James Osterberg
jr. is still in there yes absolutely he
was most most likely to succeed he
actually worked on Kennedy's campaign he
thought he might be a politician one day
now this may be a dumb question where
does the blood come from how does that
happen oh he was because he was diving
all over the stage all right